welcome everyone to choose Thursday
evening class and I will be showing you
one of my games
[Music]
from the Las Vegas tournament Nash
millionaire chess and in I'm playing a
Grand Master from Poland Poland stopa
yeah sex tapa
and he played d-46 Knight f3 f5 and I
have a question for you which opening
we're entering into here should be lots
of hands here because it's a
transposition transposition to which
opening position the Dutch the Dutch
defense ok so he goes g3 I go g3 another
six fish of G 2 3 6 b triplet my point
is to put the bishop on b2 to prevent a5
break okay because black wants to play a
5 here so I want to try to stop it
Castle castle
I go c6
see for
night a six
night be too
Queen e8 blacks idea is to try to play
e5 here at some point okay
a3
v5 trying to attack the center
I take Knight G for the idea here is I
cannot take on these six because I will
be losing the bishop on b2 okay so this
is a typical idea they sacrifice only
five and then they go 94 now Queen c2
protecting and now threatening to take
already because the bishop is guarded so
it takes
now which move should I play here let's
spend a couple of minutes here and try
to find the best move for black sorry
for white you need to see what is he
trying to do okay
so I know he wants to play efore right
he is really trying to play for and I'm
trying to see if I can try to prevent
that somehow the e for break he for push
yeah he wants to play yes perfect
now if he pushes this checkmate so he
has to play rook f7
efore
not letting him push here rook is seven
protecting a five
a four is the possibility to but I might
be able to page three tonight moves and
I can take only five okay now now he's
just somehow trying to protect the
center that's all he's trying to do
protect the center Ashish before blitzie
five actually I want to stop night see
five move and also most importantly I
want to get which idea for my night on D
- where is the night going to see for
2d6 right this is what I'm trying to go
to okay 94 96 it was 97
okay d1
now it was night b5
talking the Queen what do I do
Quincy to just retreat here knocking h8
but I think it's very concrete now I
attack him and if he goes back to c7
then I go in I see 496 so he kind of has
to go 94 we take take no that's you for
right
it's very concrete I want to put that
night on d6 once my night lens on these
six is going to be a big trouble for him
there we go
cause now I can take a 4d for everything
is falling apart that night is a monster
on this six whenever you can get a night
like this it's gonna be really really
strong so it goes here now the question
is which part are we gonna take we can
take on d4 you can take on e4 both moves
are possible but which one is the best
perfect
my egos here
no here actually if I take on d4 I
didn't like something he had Queen h6
maybe take
now threatening mate yeah
Oh h4f 493 maybe yeah this is probably
good yeah yeah it's probably good for me
yeah my idea with Bishop g2 is that when
he placed now Queen h6 I want to even
have that additional h3 move as well
okay and I also have ninety-four idea
just to protect everything and he's got
no moves basically so d4 pawn it's not
like he can defend it now Queen d2 I
want to take with the Queen on d4 and
now if I take he can take take and maybe
example and use his rook for defense so
his good defender is the the the rook on
is six right the defender so what we
want to do exchange right so with a rook
everyone now we want to trade and pick
up the pawn on d4 so you played here now
94 attacking the bishop if the bishop
goes back to e5 we're gonna play which
move now we want to get this bishop of
course for attacking it if it goes back
here we just take on d4 attacking here
so it's really really difficult like
this for him f4 is coming okay so it was
here
take
take and he actually resigned let's try
to understand why he recite yeah
probably
tick-tick-tick
now he if this was a night we go Bishop
de force it takes to the Queen what can
you do here
I see
night a5g4
in two we can start with Queen d2 as
well okay maybe that's even better
actually Queen d2 first and now you
played 396 Queen age 6 1995 24 okay
Knight h6 take and I take a look at this
and if it moves I take the Queen you
cannot defend it so if you check take
checkmate
perfect now we're gonna move forward we
got a couple of nice positions we're
gonna work on okay they're black to play
and win okay to play and win you have to
play like a very strong Grandmaster
Alexei 3f that's what I'm thinking if
you remember the answer okay let's see
really high yeah you have to work out
all that so I want you to since you know
the move I want you to work out all the
lines okay if they're a and B lines okay
a and B lines what is the idea here for
block to try to imagine it's it looks
very solid very normal and then all of a
sudden there is an idea and block is
winning
what is your crowning
maybe you need to go a little bit deeper
if you get a good candidate yeah well
that's a candidate but you gotta
calculate yeah okay there we go
Bishop d2 so if Bishop takes that's easy
we'll just go check and mate right if
Queen takes I think that's also pretty
easy to conclude that after Queen takes
a four it's just very bad because you
have ninety one threat discovery checks
okay so has to play ninety two
so you play now
King here
take on c1 let's see yes a little bit
better
therapy five creating rugby - right
now
now it was b3 rock a5 a4
getting made
to go here
mate okay
and of course if it takes back with the
rook what do you do
quincy one check Thanks checkmate okay
so this is something it's nearly
impossible to find Bishop d2 but
grandma's ad reaffirmed it okay it's
something you should be looking for okay
looking into this ideas okay and the
last one for this class white to play
and win what to do how to win this
position
you have to look at a bad position of
the king and here's some queen a3 checks
okay so they take your time take your
time a little bit so we need to get a
look on the eight that's clear
so I should suggested this I say check
now again rook e8 is still a threat it's
still out there this idea okay
perhaps h5
tribe now what to do
Queen g6
well okay a check I liked it if you go
here then we have chef Matt so it has to
go here now continue
24 check if you go see we have shock mat
and if it goes here check and if you
interpose night we take when we take he
goes here mate ok
yes sure there might be another idea
let's see
so check Oh Queen d7 here check rook
check first now I think I just swap swap
and take but it's very important not to
take right away because if you take
right away I take back with this and if
you check I have not afraid got it
so that's very important yes sir chick
chick got it
alright any questions no all right okay
guys so we finished the first class
we're gonna take a quick break and make
sure you back in about five minutes okay
for next class I have another very
important game to show you and today
you'll learn how to deal with the Dutch
defense the setup with g3 and b3 so
please try that in the practice games
first okay you can play some practice
games try that it's a good setup okay
alright I'll see you guys in a few
minutes
[Music]
you
[Music]